[Music]
this morning on the dish the improbable
journey of chef Ivan Orkin organs first
exposure to Japan was a lonely one
washing dishes in a Long Island sushi
bar when he was just 15 but he fell in
love with the cuisine and the culture
after restaurant work in this country he
moved to Tokyo and took his wife's bold
suggestion to open a ramen shop the
unlikely gamble paid off his Ivan ramen
became a hit and spawned two locations
now open here in New York now he's the
co-author of the guide Jean cookbook
Japanese recipes from a chef father
eater and lifelong outsider chef Ivan
Orkin good morning and welcome to the
hey thanks for having me so good to have
you here so what drew you to well first
of all let's talk about what we have in
front of us because it looks amazing
yeah so it's really fun to go through
the process of choosing some great
dishes for today's show all the way out
in the big bowl is tempura which is
lightly battered and fried mostly
vegetables but also we have a shrimp
version as well some roasted peppers
with a Geo today geo means salt so it's
sort of like a salty oily sauce that
really perks up the vegetables make some
delicious we have the Oh den which in
the book is the Oh den party it's fish
cakes and eggs and sausages and in a
dashi broth here we have an Okinawan
style soba which is pork belly and it's
it's delicious
and this is a rice cake that you took
toast in the toaster oven and there's
sweet beans and there's toasted soy
flour last but not least my beer the
Ivan ramen beer as we say in in Japan we
say kanpai
ah yeah combined in New York I say look
I mean the initial question is what what
brings a kid from here to his obsession
with Japan and and Japanese cuisine well
you know I got my first job ever at a
Japanese restaurant in about 1978 when
you know the whole country was not
eating Japanese food and I fell in love
with it and I'd always been very
interested in food in general but when I
got this first job they were so nice to
me
the chef's would feed me all the time
and I remember a story my first day at
work I was so hungry I was 15 I was
always hungry and I said to the chef you
know I'm really hungry and he whipped up
a raw egg he poured it over a bowl of
rice with a little bit of soy sauce and
seaweed and he said ERISA yes so I was
always I was raised to be polite you
know yeah and I had asked yes and so I
got this kind of gooey bowl of rice and
egg and I started eating and I was like
wow I mean it's kind of gooey and weird
but it's delicious
I know right I was close it was just a
part-time job so I was only there for
you know whatever it was a year or
something but it stayed with me and so
when I went to college I studied
Japanese and then I thought well I guess
I better go to live in Japan and it just
sort of starts steamrolled this this
love of Japan and I just it's my it's my
second home
well TV dinners I hear oh yeah the role
my desire to wanting to be a chef you
know my mother was never that interested
in food and so she would go to the
ballet with my dad and leave us with the
hungry man dinners I don't know if you
know this yes they never they never cook
evenly so they're always like raw on one
side and on the other side right night
just when I was 13 or 14 I put my foot
down and I said I'm never eating this
stuff again and I started to cook there
it is yeah I mean ramen is your
specialty but I mean you you call it the
Maverick cuisine of Japan it couldn't
have been easy to figure it out well you
know I used the term the Maverick
cuisine because in Japan everything is
very kind of rigid and thought out and
there's rules for everything but ramen
was the only thing that didn't have the
shop there's no rulebook all the ramen
shop owners have secrets they'll say hey
how do you make your soup and everything
the room is dense right and so you had
to figure everything out on your own and
a lot of the popular shops were popular
not just because the food was good but
because the guy was quirky or the
atmosphere was fun and so I thought to
myself you know of all the types of
cuisine or things I might try to do in
Japan as a business ramen is sort of
most forgiving it would allow me if I'm
the food good and I have a fun
atmosphere I might get a shot at opening
a place in the in a place that doesn't
necessarily welcome foreigners to cook
their crew yeah you know that's amazing
yeah and so I called the Maverick
cuisine because it's you know the ramen
shop owners are always a ragtag bunch so
I'm gonna ask you actually if you could
have this meal with anyone past or
present who would it be my first choice
will probably be Groucho Marx
I might ask Jerry Garcia oh my goodness
Billie Holiday and Charlie Parker to
join Wow that one chef Ivan Orkin as I
put my chopsticks down and show everyone
your fabulous signature if you want to
know more about him and the dish go to
our website it's cBS This Morning Calm